action Florida Congressman Michael Waltz
is with us Fox and Friends Weekend
co-host our friend Pete Heth is back
with us too you know I I listen to Joe
Biden and I hear what he asked to say
here and I listen you know and I'm just
shocked Congressman because Iran's
gotten the message that they can what
you know they've gotten the message you
know don't is the message well they're
not they're not listening to don't
because they do and they do and they do
again and again and again
well Sean as we all know don't is in a
strategy and on top of the 165 attacks
that you mentioned uh they conduct
that's since October they had conducted
78 on top of that since uh since Biden
came uh into office and I'll remind
everyone the reason we have small
numbers of special operators drone
operators and others in the Middle East
is there still going after Isis and
keeping a boot on their neck so they
don't hit us here but you know right now
they're sitting ducks uh for Iran and
their militias Sean it is it is a simple
reversal of policy you hit the irgc
operatives that are running around the
Middle East including soloman's
successor number two you drive up you
dry up the cash uh Iran's received over
a hundred billion in oil sales favors
and hostage money since Biden has come
in and number three that no one's talked
about you've had multiple uprisings
within Iran the green movement that that
Obama ignored and Masa amini uh the the
poor woman who was murdered for daring
not wear a hijab uh and the uprising
that followed from that murder let's not
sit on our hands the next time the
Iranian people say they want some change
but look we've got to reverse policy all
roads lead back to tyon instead of
playing whack-a-mole with the houthis
Hezbollah Hamas these militias and I
telling you I'm talking to soldiers down
range right now we are bombing empty
warehouses in the middle of the night so
that this Administration can check the
box and say they're doing something and
they're doing nothing that is Meaningful
and now we have F more gold star
families because of it and it's
infuriating it is infuriating and you
know at some point when they attack our
troops nearly 200 times Pete heg Seth
you know when do we come to the
conclusion that the only thing that
they're going to listen to is force now
add one other component to this and that
would be uh I keep reading and I keep
talking to sources and they keep telling
me that Iran is a lot closer to nuclear
capability than they've ever been maybe
just months away yes and I could can't
imagine a world where that radical
ideology is married to nuclear weapons I
don't think mutually assured destruction
would actually deter
them no you hit the right Point Sean
that's the headline in this is this
situation gets that much more dangerous
and difficult if Tran has nuclear
weapons and it that is that's laid at
the feet of Obama and Biden's
appeasement strategy who've gotten them
that much closer and they know it and
now they're counting on Russia to China
to have their backs as well you know
Colonel wals has been on remote bases
like I have in the middle of nowhere in
Iraq and Afghan
the only security you have you don't
know if your air defenses will
ultimately hold in any particular
situation the only security you have at
at a unit level and overall is whether
or not you can go on the offensive can
you push the initiative to kill the bad
guys and make sure they know if you
attack Americans you're dead and what
colon Walsh said is right at the micro
level at the base level I'm hearing from
guys too overseas they're not allowed to
conduct aggressive offensive operations
to secure their perimet perimeter and
take out bad guys to secure themselves
so they're sitting ducks in that context
and then they're sitting ducks on a
geopolitical context because the mulas
and Tran believe they have free range
and what is this white house talking
about Sean what's their strategy besides
don't is we want a ceasefire in Gaza
because they somehow believe that the
houthis and and the Iranians ultimately
if there's a ceasefire in Gaza they'll
stand back when all their using that as
an excuse to hit us even more and one
more thing these three Georgia
reservists three Georgia res service God
bless them deployed out of Fort Moore do
you know where Fort Moore is I don't
either do you know why cuz they renamed
it it was Fort Benning in Georgia see
this administration's been more
interested in renaming bases and social
engineering these guys by the way could
be guarding the southern border instead
they're guarding the Jordan Syrian Iraq
border and they're sitting ducks and it
it is on this Administration there's no
strategy the problem is Sean I want him
to be aggressive but who do I trust CQ
Brown Mo Austin Jo Biden KLA Harris what
do you you can't trust any of them
really no it's scary and you know what
is the net result here we're going to
have a nuclear armed Iran that ought to
puts fear into the hearts of every
American and Congressman go ahead last
word no I was just going to say look I
mean who do we trust well I'll tell you
under President Trump uh Isis Was
Defeated baghdaddy was dead Iran was
broke uh and we had the Abraham Accords
multiple uh Arab countries and Israel
our greatest Ally was stronger and
vibrant and thriving uh so I think we
know our answer come this November let's
get Donald Trump back in the White House
that our enemies
fear all right Congressman Waltz Pete
Pete hea thank you both we appreciate
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else